yes sir yes I so nice to meet you
welcome welcome this is beautiful this
is where the Templars actually hung out
in here no no this is not the Templar we
are in the right place but in the wrong
time let's go if we want to see the
temple of building we have to go down
beneath this church here this is it yeah
under this door we are going to see
another world this is like out of a
movie right now are you kidding me we're
gonna go into a secret door behind a
junk shop
let's go wow this is incredible now we
are in the right time in the right place
here we are in the 12 and 13th century
this is underground buried crypt this is
really where the Templar was 800 years
ago
[Music]
so creepy
I'm standing in a room that ancient
medieval knights the Knights Templar
hung out in yes they live here more than
two hundred eels but they never thought
it'd be a bionic food on their floor
this is the first floor of the building
but in the 13th century the Crusader
Church was above us so we were just
standing a few moments ago in another
Church right above me mm-hmm so there's
church upon Church yeah it's kind of
crazy because when you when you stand
down here it doesn't look all that
different from the church upstairs to
the style yes but if you are looking
carefully the Templar masonry it's
completely another architecture the
stones are much bigger than the 19th
century building and then it's very
famous in the Crusader period that a lot
of stones is there
masonry marks so you see here this one
oh yes exactly this one this is actually
the mark of somebody's chisel mm-hmm
from the Templar this is so cool when
you find something that you can connect
to the people that actually built this
building this is what's so excited for
me because you actually get to the
person yes exactly
further below the modern city about ten
feet beneath the Crypt are more vaults
secret chambers medieval Knights crypt
that's we've established this was a
Templar building but I don't know what
it was used for
[Music]
[Music]
this is carved out of the earth huh
hello this is for collecting rainwater
it's a huge underground water tank you
can actually see the little channel
where the water pours in from the rain
right there the only land is very very
warm we are in the Middle East and you
need the water Eliezer has excavated
three of these 25,000 gallon tanks so
far and he believes there are many more
[Music]